[Música]
y
para más llevar dos semanas de huelgas y
de cierres de calles y carreteras que
han trastocado la tranquilidad de ese
país y han dificultado también el
abastecimiento de las diferentes
regiones los manifestantes reclaman una
congelación del precio del combustible
la estabilización del costo de la
producción de y de los productos de la
canasta básica y también un descenso en
los precios de los medicamentos
esto coincide con el intento de las
autoridades de sacar adelante la
economía panameña tras los meses álgidos
de la pandemia de kobe 19 que llevaron a
un cierre de la mayoría de los comercios
en ese país pero a este contexto también
hay que añadirle un cierto digamos
hartazgo de los ciudadanos ante las
constantes denuncias de actos de
corrupción pública y de clientelismo
político que han llevado a un
descontento por buena parte de la
población a grandes rasgos pues está la
situación que se está presentando en
panamá en el siguiente informe hecho por
la redacción de france 24 profundizamos
en este tema veamos
panamá se sumó a la ola de protestas
latinoamericanas de los últimos años un
descontento que coincide con la invasión
de rusia ucrania guerra que ha
trastocado las economías de todo el
mundo pero que ha desnudado problemas
estructurales
ya son más de dos semanas de las
protestas más grandes desde la caída en
1989 del dictador manuel antonio noriega
se empiezan a ver imágenes de
desabastecimiento por los cortes de vía
en unas marchas iniciadas por maestros
ya las que se fueron sumando otros
sectores desde la construcción hasta el
movimiento indígena
la inflación interanual se sitúa en un
42 los principales reclamos son
consecuencia del golpe al bolsillo del
ciudadano el precio del combustible
aumentó en un 47 por ciento en los
últimos seis meses y el galón llegó a
superar los cinco dólares antes de ser
reducido por el gobierno el índice de
precios al consumidor aumentó en un 3,3
por ciento respecto a 2021 por lo que
también se han congelado el aumento del
coste de 10 alimentos de la canasta
básica pero más allá del momento panamá
tiene 4 millones de habitantes el 20 por
ciento de la población vive en
condiciones de pobreza y la mitad
trabaja en empleos informales
eso en un país que en 2021 creció un 17
8% y que posee un canal que le reporta 2
mil millones de dólares al año sin
embargo es uno de los países más
desiguales en el mundo con frecuentes
casos de corrupción como el popular
macro caso de la constructora brasileña
odebrecht que salpica a los dos últimos
ex presidentes
bueno pero panamá no es el único país
que está experimentando una oleada de
manifestaciones de descontento y
exigencias por parte de los ciudadanos
en días anteriores vimos tanto a
seguidores del peronismo como de la
izquierda tomarse las calles de la
capital argentina a la ciudad de buenos
aires- y todo esto en reclamo por más
ayuda estatal para contrarrestar la alta
inflación que se está presentando en ese
país suramericano
diferentes sectores sindicales
argentinos exigen al gobierno del
presidente alberto fernández un bono de
unos 20 mil pesos argentinos eso es más
o menos unos 148 dólares estadounidenses
para poder hacer frente al incremento de
los precios de productos de la canasta
básica también piden un incremento en el
salario mínimo que en este país ronda
los 45 mil 540 pesos argentinos es decir
unos 340 dólares estadounidenses también
piden una mejora en los programas
laborales que otorga el estado o
subsidios también los podemos llamar así
que sucede entonces en estos dos países
de américa latina- que hay más de este
contexto de lo que se puede ver
superficialmente que se está presentando
tanto entre los panameños como los
argentinos que los ha llevado a ir a la
calle a tomarse las calles de las
principales ciudades del país o de los
diferentes países haciendo exigencias
algo que es completamente válido porque
los ciudadanos están avalados por las
constituciones para poder salir a
reclamar y hacerle exigencias a los
gobiernos pero hay que entender el
origen de estos motivos para hacer este
tipo de reclamos sociales nos vamos a
poner en perspectiva entonces aquí en el
programa el debate de france 24 para
analizar este tema entonces saludamos a
la doctora grace jaramillo ella es
profesora adjunta de la universidad de
british columbia de la escuela de
políticas públicas y relaciones
internacionales en la ciudad de
vancouver en canadá y desde ciudad de
mexico se conecta con nosotros hugo con
charles investigador del instituto de
investigaciones jurídicas de la unam en
la capital de la republica mexicana les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar sus
preguntas y sus comentarios a través en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
twitter en instagram en facebook ustedes
ya las conocen no se encuentran como
france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta se la recuerdo para que dejen
sus comentarios numeral el debate efe 24
también aprovechó para recordarles que
en youtube pueden encontrar nuestra
señal de streaming y también aprovecho
para saludar a las personas que nos
están escuchando a través de nuestro
podcast los invito para que escuchen
todos los contenidos del debate de
france 24 que ya están disponibles en
app el podcast en spotify deezer y tiene
en
pues muy bien comienzo entonces este
análisis sobre la situación de estos dos
países en particular en américa latina'
con la doctora grace en la ciudad de
vancouver en el oeste de canadá punto de
partida doctora grace bienvenida al
debate gracias por estar con nosotros y
el punto de partida para conocer
impresiones de lo que está sucediendo
como cree usted o cómo evalúa usted las
dos perspectivas que se están
presentando tanto en panamá como en
argentina más allá de este reclamo
ciudadano hay un descontento
generalizado en américa latina' frente a
las políticas de los gobiernos hay un
poco de falta de sintonía entre lo que
buscan las autoridades y lo que están
pidiendo de verdad las sociedades de los
diferentes países cuál es su análisis
muy buenas tardes
santiago y gracias por la invitación yo
creo que hay tres variables comunes que
yo diría que no sólo corresponden a lo
que pasa en américa latina sino también
explican un poco lo que pasa en sri
lanka por ejemplo lo que pasó en el re
lanka pero sigue pasando en los países
bajos en donde miles de agricultores
están tratando de boicotear el gobierno
para el gobierno e incluso detener las
políticas de cambio climático que han
ralentizado la producción y además van a
generar una escasez de alimento entonces
yo diría que estas tres
variables comunes de esta crisis primero
es que ninguna la mayor parte de
gobiernos no ha tenido ninguna
innovación o salida de política pública
frente a la crisis primero causada por
el hobbit luego por la guerra en ucrania
pero sobre todo por el desempleo y la
recesión productiva que esto generó y ya
está generando en la mayoría de países
población está mayormente en crisis en
américa latina' a esto se suma el hecho
de que la mayor parte del empleo era
subempleo o informalidad estamos
hablando del desempleo informal o las
personas en informalidad en panamá más o
menos en el 67 por ciento de la
población eso es altísimo y eso
significa que muchas de esas familias no
tienen que comer cada día regularmente
hay la segunda parte que es aún más
dramática es que las respuestas en
términos económicos y políticos
no se canalizan ya a través de los
partidos políticos ya sea en el gobierno
o en la oposición y eso me parece aún
más grave porque no hay salidas
políticas de esta crisis si usted ve en
el caso de panamá por ejemplo
primero fue movimientos aleatorios
los los profesores los maestros luego se
crea un movimiento llamado la alianza
nacional por los derechos del pueblo
organizado a nadie po que negocia
indistintamente con el gobierno pero
aparte también está la ley por la vida
sí y entonces el uno no negocia con el
otro
a nadie por logra alcanzar el acuerdo el
17 de julio recién este domingo
firmaron un acuerdo para detener la
gasolina a 3.25 dólares por galón pero
hay otros movimientos que se oponen
porque requieren respuestas mucho más
claras digamos estructurales a la crisis
entonces esta crisis de representación
es lo que está causando que no haya
salidas fáciles no haya posibilidades de
consenso rápido ni siquiera acuerdos
programáticos que uno pueda leer una
visión de cómo se cierra el tema a corto
importante y buena perspectiva doctora
grace desde la ciudad de vancouver en
canadá paso ahora desde vancouver nos
vamos a esta ciudad de mexico allí está
conectado hubo concha también le doy la
bienvenida al programa gracias por
acompañarnos punto de partida hugo estos
reclamos ciudadanos hay sintonía
entonces entre las molestias de las
diferentes de los diferentes ciudadanos
es un escenario similar entonces
argentina lo que estamos viendo en
panamá lo que vimos hace un par de años
en otros países como colombia chile
donde simplemente esto lleva al mismo
punto de partida un descontento social y
una falta de sintonía entre los
gobiernos y sus respectivas sociedades
como lo vio usted si yo creo que
independientemente de que en cada uno de
nuestros países estas manifestaciones
pueden tener banderas específicas
distintas yo creo que la doctora
jaramillo atina muy bien al ver una
corriente una tendencia común
es llevar este
las protestas que las detonan en la
mayor parte de los casos problemas de
tipo económico pero que al final del día
tienen un significado profundo en la
política o en la interacción y actividad
política que está sucediendo en estas en
esta década en todos nuestros países que
quiero decir con esto es llama la
atención que justamente se presentan
estas crisis económicas justo curvando
la población también está más empoderada
o en pleno ejercicio de sus derechos a
la presentación del vídeo cuando
hablabas de la crisis en panamá salvador
justamente todo habla si existen una
pequeña reflexión sobre el significado
de las
manifestaciones efectiva infestación es
un ejercicio vital de toda democracia
constitucional
el derecho a la libre expresión la
libertad de expresión que todas las
constituciones democráticas
tienen como una de sus principales de
sus principales ejes sus principales
fuentes y estamos viendo que la
ciudadanía las está utilizando para
quejarse en un primer ámbito
aparentemente más específico en contra
de problemas económicos alzas cierres
etcétera inflación desempleo pero que al
final del grado hay un enorme
descontento y ahí es quizá donde yo
quisiera llevar más de discusión si un
enorme descontento con las instituciones
con la gestión gubernamental que se está
dando en muchos de nuestros países y que
además es un fenómeno que tiene además
de que tiene muchas aristas lo podemos
conectar también con este otro fenómeno
en los politólogos han estado estudiando
de cómo han estado surgiendo
alternativas políticas
etiquetadas todos bajo la bandera del
populismo pero distintos tipos y formas
clark en toda la región en toda la
región no son fenómenos aislados ni
separados es un mismo fenómeno
el desgaste el desgaste de instituciones
el desgaste de gobiernos que ya no
logran dar una respuesta distinta a los
márgenes de acción que tienen son muy
pequeñitos claro esto no satisface a
éstos a la pobla a las poblaciones a la
ciudadanía en las demandas que están
teniendo que digamos el momento de la
mayor ciudadanía democrática en el
momento del mayor desgaste institucional
de los gobiernos claro y creo que ese
malestar coincide en los diferentes
países con un punto de quiebre clave que
es la la pandemia de kobe 19 que llegó
ya a ser un punto de explosión digamos
para la sociedad no solamente en américa
latina porque ya lo vemos en otros en
otros puntos del planeta pero vamos
analizando la situación de nuestra
región quiero que nos enfoquemos en el
caso de panamá llama mucho la atención
normalmente panamá es un país tranquilo
es un país que no tiene mayores
sobresaltos
en su sociedad a nivel de violencia es
una sociedad que pocas veces se
manifiesta en las calles no es como
vamos a analizar el caso argentina donde
constantemente los argentinos salen
demostrar su descontento en las calles
por diferentes puntos de vista es una
sociedad un poco más empoderada digamos
en ese en ese sentido y tal vez la
diferencia entre los dos países es que
argentina viene arrastrando una crisis
económica desde hace muchos años pero
panamá venía muy bien económicamente
hasta que empezó la pandemia de kobe 19
y empezó a registrar un
una una contracción de su producto
interno bruto que llegó para el 20 por
ciento más o menos para el 2020 y empezó
a recuperarse a medida que la economía
se fue abriendo y el país fue
recuperando otra vez la normalidad como
es el contexto panameño cómo es este
país
pequeño cuatro millones de habitantes
jugó la mayor parte de la población ya
le doy la palabra doctora gracias para
hacer la ronda la inversa que está muy
concentrado en la actividad del canal la
actividad comercial de ciudad de panamá
que hay del resto de la periferia que
hay de las otras regiones del país que
justamente es donde empezaron las
manifestaciones
así es es un fenómeno sin duda muy
interesante justamente por las
dimensiones que tiene panamá y porque la
verdad de las cosas es que para los que
estamos atentos a lo que ocurre
políticamente en la región la verdad
efectivamente panamá no nos había
llamado la atención desde hace tiempo no
la llamo con los panamá papers pero que
en realidad es un elemento muy
específico y que tiene que ver con otra
cosa
con corrupción de ciertos grupos de fini
y con y con triangulación es de lavado
de dinero pero no tenía nada que ver con
la población panameña como tú muy bien
lo estás poniendo en la mesa la verdad
las cosas que es un país chico en donde
la verdad no habíamos escuchado mayores
manifestaciones en los últimos años no
recuerdo que es a lo último que supimos
de panamá a este nivel y de de las
reacciones que sucedían en panamá pues
probablemente fueron cuando los
problemas con el canal fuera de esto la
verdad de las cosas es que no teníamos
en el radar situaciones a este nivel de
descontento con la sociedad panameña
precisamente por ser una ciudad por una
sociedad relativamente pequeña en
términos comparativos de 4 millones
mucha gente pero en términos
comparativos con el resto de los países
de la región pues una sociedad pequeña
una sociedad en donde aparentemente él
la economía
satisfacía no de manera
tolerable de manera satisfactoria las
necesidades de esta misma sociedad y de
repente ahora estamos viendo pues que
esas cosas no son así justamente y que
además no no a diferencia de otros
países más grandes no es sólo en la
capital donde esto explota lo que llama
mucho la atención justamente porque
quiere decir que las condiciones
económicas y las condiciones de trabajo
y de vida en todo el país están se están
viendo afectadas de manera muy alta
llamaba la atención también cuando
empieza todas estas protestas que varias
de los manifestantes llegaban a decir no
sé nos hemos aguantado o hemos tolerado
esto por muchos años pero ya no
te habla te hablo un poco de esto que
también mencionábamos anteriormente de
que no es la primera vez que la sociedad
panameña se siente agraviada se sienten
harán tomada en cuenta esto es muy
importante no tomada en cuenta por estas
decisiones que vienen del gobierno que
vienen normalmente de la administración
y que filtró que finalmente ya tocaron
fondo suponen fondo en donde duele a la
sociedad se apuntó no tengo para
analizar si justamente al presidente de
laurentino ortiz
llega en el momento equivocado y le toca
hacer frente este tipo de de le toca
hacer frente a este tipo de
manifestaciones para el descontento
viene de mucho más atrás doctora grace
jaramillo en la ciudad de vancouver en
canadá no sé qué tan disiente pueda
hacer en los diferentes grupos que se
han armado de manifestaciones en panamá
veíamos a los agricultores a los
pescadores artesanales en el interior de
panamá llegaron a un acuerdo inicial
pero vemos otra cara de la moneda y de
quienes están manifestándose en las
autopistas de ciudad de panamá
bloqueando el acceso al aeropuerto
internacional de tocumen son las
centrales sindicales son los profesores
son otro el sindicato de la construcción
que es muy poderoso en panamá vemos dos
caras de la moneda
esto que nos puede decir de este país
desde sus bases sociales es un país
netamente que concentra la parte del
desarrollo en ciudad de panamá y la zona
de la periferia de las regiones están
bastante descuidadas por la
administración de los presidentes
panameños cuál es su análisis
exactamente y le voy a dar una cifra al
respecto del
85% del producto interno bruto de panamá
solo se produce en dos provincias en la
de colon y en la de panamá que tiene
directamente que ver con el comercio
internacional comer sin servicios el
gran crecimiento de panamá que
experimentó por hace 10 años altas tasas
de crecimiento en general se debieron a
servicios financieros es decir estamos
hablando de un crecimiento tan
significativo que había
necesariamente llegado a un punto de
inflexión y este es el punto de
inflexión que estamos viendo por eso es
que por primera vez al menos en los
últimos 30 años o más de vida
democrática después de la caída del
dictador noriega en panamá que se
levanta desde los diferentes grupos de
base no como usted ve también no tiene
ninguna relación con los partidos
partidos políticos tradicionales del
presidente cortizo viendo del partido de
la revolución democrática que ha
gobernado frecuentemente panamá esos
últimos 30 años está el partido
panameñista que también ha gobernado en
varias ocaciones panamá pero con una con
un telón de fondo que también está
pesando entre los panameños digamos los
más los sectores más vulnerables y es el
hecho de que a pesar del crecimiento
económico increíble hay los casos de
corrupción tan dramáticos como the other
break han estado esa cortina de humo
sobre cualquier redistribución de la red
esta redistribución del desarrollo en
otras provincias que no sea ese 85% que
acapara la mayor parte de la riqueza de
panamá y el resto de provincias que son
8 provincias en panamá tan sólo tienen
acceso a este 15% o usted redistribuye
se 15% apenas en esas provincias y es
desde esas provincias frente a las
grandes a los grandes centros de poder
económico y político
colom y panamá en donde se hace esa
brecha cada vez más grande cada vez más
polarizada podemos hacer una serie de
semejanzas disímiles con lo que pasa en
otros países el ecuador acaba de pasar
18 días en huelga una paralización
nacional similar donde efectivamente se
dan en esta suerte de dicotomía entre
campo y ciudad que se vuelven cada vez
más dramáticas con una clase media
boyante en la ciudad con acceso a
recursos pero también a mano de obra
barata tanto en el tema de la
construcción como usted bien dijo
santiago pero también en el tema de
acceso a productos de primera necesidad
y alimentos baratos mientras tanto el
campo ha sido totalmente descuidado
afectado aún más por la pandemia y yo
creo que eso es lo que vemos ahora de
golpe estallar en panamá cuando habíamos
visto un país muy tan claro y que la
imagen que tenemos es esta ciudad de
panamá llena de rascacielos con bancos
donde mucha gente va de compras
comercialmente muy activo el tránsito
de los barcos a través del canal pero a
nivel rural es otra historia
completamente diferente lo que pasa en
las provincias y tres en bocas del toro
en david y en las provincias sobre todo
que están del lado del tapón del darién
que es una zona selvática lejos del
desarrollo tecnológico que puede tener
una ciudad como ciudad de panamá
doctora jaramillo quiero que hablemos de
la figura del presidente
laurentino cortizo ahorita dije ortiz
hago la corrección me equivoqué en el
apellido laurentino cortizo esta figura
que tanto margen de negociación tiene
que tanto puede ceder ante estos
reclamos teniendo en cuenta que los
reclamos vienen por dos áreas distintas
ahora están pidiendo una mesa de
negociación unificada pero qué tan
rápido podrían llegar a ponerse de
acuerdo ambas partes estos
representantes de las zonas rurales y
estos sindicatos en ciudad de panamá
para hacer un reclamo en conjunto al
presidente cortizo
el problema real es que el presidente
cortizo está en el poder desde el 2019
con una agenda además con una demanda de
causar cambios rápidos y
productivos sobre todo en el agro y no
ha podido responder a estas demandas
yo diría en la forma necesariamente
eficiente que demandaba la actitud del
joven
en la cancha yo creo que la pelota está
en más bien en la cancha de los
movimientos sociales que puedan
organizarse adecuadamente en un frente
único para presentar demandas de cambio
de políticas públicas de gentes es otro
de los elementos clave de la crisis
también es la asamblea nacional es decir
se trata de un congreso que no ha
tramitado rápidamente proyectos
productivos de reactivación del campo
que éste ha estado pidiendo por
dos a más de dos años y que no se
procesan entonces yo creo que en la
salida a la crisis va más del lado de
los movimientos sociales de los sectores
de órganos e incluso de frente unitario
de trabajadores y la asociación de
constructores para poder establecer una
plataforma común porque no le veo al
presidente cortizo con la capacidad ni
la agilidad para tener el liderazgo en
la salida del acto y le pregunto a hugo
en la ciudad de mexico su perspectiva
como lo decía la doctora jaramillo en el
terreno la pelota de qué lado está desde
su perspectiva y esto que costo político
le amplió la pregunta que el costo
político tiene para el presidente
cortizo y para la economía panameña que
la que está sufriendo
fuertemente a lo largo de estas dos
semanas
y yo creo que los días que vienen que
vienen van a ser claves justamente
porque de santiago pero justamente
porque veremos las capacidades de
negociación de las dos partes y
efectivamente un poco el tipo de
exigencias específicas que las
organizaciones los sindicatos pongan en
la mesa que sean alcanzables que sean
viables para que el gobierno pueda
responder va a ser el detonador de esta
negociación si efectivamente lo que
estas organizaciones
ponen es una cosa
realizable es viable pues entonces si
será un tema totalmente del gobierno
como lo maneja como lo lo asimila y como
lo lleva a cabo el desgaste sin lugar a
dudas es alto este ya llegó y está
instalado es decir hoy en día ya la
protesta la protesta exige una vez que
esto sucede pues esto trae un desgaste
muy fuerte al gobierno en turno ahora
veremos las habilidades que no hemos
tenido oportunidad de ver porque lo
platicamos anteriormente esto no había
sucedido de qué tan tantas habilidades
justamente para el diálogo para
encontrar los puntos de acuerdo y ser en
todo caso hacer propuestas concretas
tendrá el gobierno actual pero digamos
lo digo así porque creo que no no sólo
depende de una de las partes no sólo
depende en este momento del gobierno ni
sólo las organizaciones dar una buena
negociación en una buena negociación las
dos partes tienen que mostrar
habilidades tienen que mostrar digamos
talento para poder llegar a un acuerdo
específico 6 nunca será nunca será este
acuerdo lo que una sola de las partes
quisiera justamente se tienen que
encontrar puntos intermedios en esa
negociación y eso es lo que veremos sin
lugar a dudas y los próximos días ambas
partes tienen que ceder en algunos de
los puntos y en algunas concesiones
tendrán que coincidir en hugo para hacer
también la ronda a la inversa le
pregunto
estamos ante un momento crítico de la
democracia panameña o la situación no es
tan grave como para verlo así lo
pregunto porque es un país muy pequeño
muy tranquilo en el que normalmente no
veíamos estos bloqueos tan grandes lo
que hemos visto de la parálisis de
ciudad de panamá es es algo que no
veíamos ustedes ya lo mencionaban desde
hace varias décadas atrás sobre todo
desde 1989 como por citar un momento
crítico en la historia de la política
panameña pero pero está en crisis está
en riesgo al borde del abismo hay
riesgos políticos mayores acá o esto con
una buena negociación que tome lo que
tome de tiempo puede llegar a un buen
puerto
yo creo que estamos ahí en esa última
parte que tú mencionas yo creo que
todavía hay un muy buen espacio y
espacio muy importante para la
negociación en donde obviamente no todos
quedarán totalmente satisfechos ni
contentos pero si veo todavía hay un
margen importante para el
reencausamiento digamos de la normalidad
hasta donde ésta se puede llamar en
nuestros países tan desiguales pero esta
normalidad
funcional canción a la sociedad como
para el gobierno veo que estamos todavía
ahí pero si veo que si esto no se llega
a producir esta negociación no es
exitosa sin lugar a dudas panamá nos va
a dar muchísimo más de que hablar de lo
que nos agradan en los últimos años yo
creo que me atrevo a decir algo más sexy
que falta y tú el moderador de santiago
hablaremos específicamente argentina
pero también tenemos que ir siendo muy
cuidadosos en el análisis y en la
observación de los elementos comunes
como como inició la discusión de los
elementos comunes que estas protestas
están llevando a cabo porque también
existe la posibilidad que estamos viendo
inicio de un movimiento o un
cuestionamiento profundo a las
democracias constitucionales modelos a
final de cuentas y dos con muchos
elementos de distintas partes en nuestra
región y que tanto sigue siendo siguen
siendo los modelos funcionales pero
hablar de primaveras porque esas ya
sucedieron hacia alguna una más de una
década pero probablemente que estemos
viviendo algún tipo de movimiento
regional de la larga profundidad pues
justamente usted encontró la pregunta
que tenía para el cierre del programa
puede ir pensando la respuesta a hugo
doctora ya usted tiene un avance de lo
que vamos a hablar para elegir para la
conclusión del programa me queda ya
pocos minutos dentro del bloque final
del programa y quiero que pasemos a
argentina rápidamente panamá nos tomó un
poco más de tiempo finalmente es un país
que está llamando más la atención en
este momento sin quitarle peso a lo que
está sucediendo en argentina pero
doctora jaramillo argentina un país que
venía arrastrando una crisis económica
complicada llega a enfrentar la crisis
de la pandemia con muchos problemas y
ahora pues trata de recuperarse pero con
una inflación
muy complicado los niveles que se están
manejando allí un gran descontento de
los argentinos un gran desencanto de la
sociedad argentina pero sobre todo
muchas divisiones al interior del
gobierno que se dificulta encontrar
caminos para salir de los problemas cual
es su panorama del caso argentino de
estas manifestaciones que se están
presentando
yo creo que bien ha dicho es decir
santiago usted ya resumió cuál es el
perdón al adelantamiento puede
profundizar
no por cierto si lo que pasa en este
momento es que en un momento en que
argentina necesitaba un plan de
reactivación económica a gran escala que
realmente catapulte la producción
argentina de exportación la agricultura
doméstica para un consumo local tanto
como la exportación
de bienes agrícolas es en lo que
realmente destaca argentina eso no ha
pasado y en parte no ha pasado porque
los problemas internos de esta pugna
entre entre el presidente alberto
fernández y la vicepresidenta cada vez
se vuelve más crítica está por emitirse
el fallo sobre el caso vialidad del caso
de corrupción contra cristina fernández
de kirchner y en este momento en uno de
los momentos más difíciles que ha tenido
que vivir alberto fernández como
presidente precisamente por la presión
económica por la presión la demanda
popular de cambios dramáticos de la
activación del agro de reactivación
productiva
la vicepresidenta sale con un mensaje de
que hay un intento de golpe o del
golpe de estado casi casi por parte de
la corte por el caso vialidad entonces
hay una desconexión total que el
gobierno argentino respecto a la
necesidad urgente de tomar acciones y
eso es lo que agrava el caso argentino
con un añadido el que más y es en el
tema de la renegociación con el fondo
monetario internacional tenían esto
estaban las portas de negociar 40 mil
millones de dólares con el fondo
monetario internacional y eso requería
una reactivación productiva a la par que
mantener como al menos bajo los índices
de inflación el crecimiento del gasto
fiscal y esto no ha pasado entonces esa
crisis institucional se está agravando
porque en un pueblo que demanda
respuestas tiene un gobierno que no
demanda respuesta o sea no da respuestas
y no sólo eso sino que por dos lados con
acusaciones mutuas con temas de
corrupción o con acusaciones de la
crisis en ucrania que no vienen al caso
en donde se agrava la crisis y tal
parece que siempre hay un factor externo
que es el que provoca los problemas en
argentina de acuerdo a lo que dicen los
políticos de ese país siempre la culpa
es de un tercero en google por el caso
de argentina precisamente esto que
hablaba yo de este factor externo que
siempre hay alguna hay algún punto a
quien echarle la culpa de la situación
vemos que los diferentes gobiernos están
metidos en este mismo espiral todos los
gobiernos argentinos recientes por lo
menos de la última década o dos décadas
han estado en exactamente la misma
posición una grave situación económica
muchas dificultades sociales no importa
si el gobierno es de izquierdas de
derechas si son los kirchner si es macri
argentina no logra salir de ese espiral
que es lo que pasa políticamente y
socialmente en ese país
si yo tuviera la respuesta concreta
el presidente argentina
[Música]
es decir porque efectivamente es uno de
los grandes misterios de la
consolidación del estado argentino no
porque teniendo tanto carece también de
tanto es decir porque no logran
estabilizar al país económica y
políticamente la ruptura que el gobierno
actual vive el gobierno de alberto
fernández es muy es muy
significativa por lo que acarrea estos
grupos políticos que ni siquiera logran
ponerse de acuerdo en la forma en que se
divide en el pastel es decir es
increíble y creo que lo que está pasando
en este momento en argentina sí sí está
para llamar mucho la atención y prender
focos rojos porque de haberse iniciado
protestas en un sentido
como un poco muy parecido a lo que
ocurría en otros países protestas otra
vez con el tema económico con el tema de
la recesión producida por la pandemia ya
en las manifestaciones argentinas
si hay un claro componente político hay
un claro componente que está exigiendo
la salida de cristina kirchner este
demandas en contra el presidente
fernando es decir yo veo que las
manifestaciones empezaron con distintos
temas se han agudizado mucho porque la
inflación además no la logran controlar
tema tampoco nada nuevo para la
argentina
y se ha convertido en una en un reclamo
mucho más político y muy dirigido y muy
dirigido a los actores es decir no está
nada más resuelve este tema del
desempleo y listo no si no queremos a
caer en tramos no queremos alberto son
reclamos muy puntuales y de enorme
trabajo nombre y apellido con nombre y
apellido exacta me quedan me quedan dos
minutos se me fue el programa hablando
más de panamá argentina bueno lo podemos
tratar en otro en otro programa en otra
oportunidad a lo largo de los próximos
días para la conclusión y el cierre pues
tocó un poco lo que decía hugo en esa
pregunta y en ese comentario que hacía
sobre esta crisis que hay del modelo
democrático esa falta de afinidad entre
los pueblos y quienes gobiernan y sobre
todo esa falta de credibilidad de la
institucionalidad de los gobiernos
latinoamericanos para dónde va qué rumbo
vamos a tener en estos países en esta y
sobre todo en este problema económico en
el que estamos la mayoría de estados con
alta inflación comienzo con la doctora
grace jaramillo para darle la palabra
una cosa que debemos de enfocarnos en el
tema de gobernabilidad es cierto que hay
una crisis de las instituciones
democráticas en todo el continente pero
recordemos que hay una parte que todos
se han olvidado políticas públicas para
el agro hay un problema grave con el
tema del desarrollo rural que debemos
volver la vista es el regreso de nuevo a
los ochentas y en los 90s pero en eso
esta américa latina y tanto en panamá
como en argentina eso se ha descuidado
políticas públicas serias para el siglo
21 es realmente lo que necesita a parte
de una red constitucional reconstitución
de las instituciones de hizo contacto
con el poder real que los ciudadanos
clark y hugo para el cierre su
conclusión si yo estando de acuerdo con
la autora amara jara para mí yo creo que
inicia el tema de la inconformidad por
la falta de políticas públicas eficaces
pero rápidamente esto encuentra eco en
una crisis a la representación política
no es decir y no es cosa menor
que tanto las instituciones en la manera
en que están estructuradas en la manera
en que se integran en nuestros distintos
países que son diferentes mecanismos
están siendo instituciones que logran
llegar a las y los mecanismos de salida
a las respuestas que las sociedades
están necesitando y que ella hoy en día
desde hace algunos años están reclamando
a gritos sí me parece que ahí es donde
está la crisis política en una crisis de
representación política que ahí sí con
distintos colores y formas y nombres
claro está extendida en la región y es
ahí cuando se conecta con este tema de
los nuevos tipos de gobierno lo que va a
pasar después de estos gobiernos que
llegan al poder diciendo así o somos
distintos a lo de antes la verdad es que
ya no tenemos muchas más alternativas no
hay muchas trabas y añado un componente
un ingrediente más a todo este problema
y es la corrupción que tal parece que es
algo transversal para todos los países
puede tener una muy buena
institucionalidad puede haber unas muy
buenas políticas pero mientras la
corrupción siga presente a los niveles
que presenta américa latina creo que va
a ser muy difícil encontrar una salida a
todo este espiral que estamos viviendo
en nuestra región doctora grace
jaramillo en la ciudad de vancouver en
canadá y auguró concha en la ciudad de
mexico les agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros y haber hecho este análisis
para la audiencia de france 24 ustedes
pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales y sigan con la programación de
france 24
[Música]